سلام اخير وداع من تحت الانقاض خيبه تلو
الاخرى ركام لا يلفظ الا الجسد والقليل من
الحياه صباح اخر والكارثه تتوسع وتضيق
فيها فرص النجاه
يتفقد هذا الرجل الحطام محاوله متعثره
للبحث عن عائلته ابتلعت الانقاض ما لا يقل
عن 17 من افراد اسرته حتى الان لم تسعفه
ذاكرته حتى بعد ان جفت الدموع قال لك
راحوا اخوي
ونسوان اثنين معه
كارثه مدويه
تحايل عليها المنقذون على امل سماع من
يطلب النجاه
صوت من بطن الارض هذا المراد لا غير
تسير عمليات الانقاذ بلا توقف وبحسب خبراء
الفتره الذهبيه لانقاذ الارواح في مثل هذه
الكوارث شارفت على الانتهاء ونقص الغذاء
وطقس البارد عاملان توفرهما يزيد المشهد
مراره
الاطفال الاوفر حظا في النجاه رغم وفاه
الالاف منهم لكن ما ينتظرهم مقلق وفق
اليونيسف غالبيه الاطفال ينجون دون
عائلاتهم ما يعمق من ازمه الطفوله
المفقوده في سوريا طوال السنين الماضيه
ضحايا كارثه الزلزال يقترب عددهم من
العشرين الف قتيل في سوريا وتركيا راحوا
جميعهم في حادثه تزلزلت فيها الارض ودكه
من عليها
غذاء السالم العربيه